it is so wonderful to see you anthony
tia
and loretta you know family reunion it
does such a great job of of course
making us laugh but you also do an
incredible job
of really you know hitting us in the
fields and you amplify
really important issues so i'm curious
uh anthony let's start with you
what is it like for you to authentically
represent
black families on screen i think it's
it's something that you don't take
lightly
i think uh when you know that you have a
show let alone a successful show that
people are watching i think we all go
into it knowing the gravity
of the choices that we make and kind of
the way that we portray
our culture because i think especially
in this time it's very sensitive
and i think uh making sure that you walk
that line between
opening things up for black culture and
allowing people to see different aspects
of us but still
having that strong representation of
being like this is who we are this is
what we've been
through and this is where we're going no
matter what and i think that
that balance is what makes this show
very successful
and loretta what is it like for you to
authentically represent a black family
on television
you know all you can do is mimic your
mom your grandmother and the women that
you've come in contact with and the
women that you know
that love their families this is about a
family where everybody really loves each
other and
everybody has everybody's back and i
think that that is what people love to
see
a bad or good because i believe in
spankings and and miss tia
don't so all these things these issues
that keep coming up
when you watch the show right old school
versus new school
um and tia you really spoiled us this
season
we don't get one we don't get two we get
three
real housewives cameos thank you
so much for inviting me on your show to
promote c
by coco it should be called cheap by
coco
seeing coco going head to head
with these housewives what was it like
for you to be in your first
real housewife style brawl let me tell
you
it was definitely entertaining and you
know i got a little bit of
practice behind the scenes it's so funny
like even before
we started um you know saying our lines
and acting each of the girls like walked
up to me and
you know kind of uh you know told me a
little stuff you know
about each other i was like oh okay okay
oh wow
okay and then action you know what i
mean but um
it was it was a lot of fun these girls
are they're so professional they're so
great at um acting like they were
they were so wonderful it was it was a
lot of fun
very entertaining should i say i was
like enjoying myself
my daughter jordan or you know that's a
real name i like when she goes
wrong road wrong road wrong
road i was dying
wrong road wrong road wrong
road well i have to say i know i know
you a little bit in real life and you're
such a nice person and to see you really
bring the claws out um it was a true uh
moment to behold now i'm i'm gonna put
you three on the spot a little bit here
this is gonna
require a little creativity you know the
housewives are famous for their taglines
if you don't like my shade then step out
of my shadow
i'd rather spend my life kicking ass
than kissing it
reading is fundamental and honey i own
the library i'm hoping i can get a real
housewife style
tag line from each of you three it's
gonna take two plates for that one
how do you want it that's it shut up
girl
you better be blind tia i gotta go back
to you you can
just hear me tia come on you can do this
wait you mean i create my own tagline
yeah
i'm just gonna say wrong roll the wrong
row wrong
that's jordan's tag line okay
tia you think about it anthony i'm gonna
go to you what what would your tagline
be
what you see is what you get
god is never gonna get you more than you
can have
he's cutting it awfully close tia you
gotta give me the
you are dramatic you're helping me you
come from me i come for you
is that one oh my gosh
isn't it yes you come for me i hope for
you
love it don't mess with my family don't
mess with my family you come from me
i come for you mm-hmm that's that's it
do you approve loretta
that's a good one yes okay okay okay
[Music]